[Music]
i have a student
that i met when he was in
the ninth grade in high school
we have this bond
where i'm encouraging him because he had
many different ideas of what he wanted
to do but i said you have an aptitude
for engineering you should stick it up
oh it's hard i don't want to do it i say
stick it out
because
you
are a strong young man
you can do this and i am here to help
you and i can find somebody to help you
i'm not an engineer i can't help you
with the engineering work but
um but we i we have a ton of engineers
here at mit making laboratory that will
help you
and telling him to stay in touch when he
went to college
is key
and he did
and he even visited me here at lincoln
lab and asked to speak to other
scientists here at the lab to kind of
pick their brain about engineering
and then
next thing you know he's here as an
intern
and then he became a full-time employee
and now he is getting his mba at mit
sloan so when he called me like this
would not happen and he didn't push me
or you know thank you for being in my
corner and all of that but i said you
know that's what i do i would have done
that for anybody
she's a person
who will do things for other people
and never seek any recognition for it
and it's just very subtle you know and
she's such a humble person that's why it
was great and it was an honor to
nominate her because you know i've known
her for 12 years we've been colleagues
for 12 years and you know she's she was
she's perfect for what the institute
ought to be promoting in its mlk
leadership award
perfect
i just want to thank everybody for this
honor
it's really appreciated and i hold it
close to my heart
you